20 meters Final Approach
10 meters
and our simulation might have lost its
connection with the MCC no
reason to for concern yet we are still
seeing the animation going three
kilometers per hour
only meters above the surface now
and now we are at the moment of planned
Landing time again everyone please give
us a few moments to confirm
we hope to maybe receive a message from
our MCC soon
if that is not the case then we will
need a few moments to continue
investigations and we'll update you as
soon as we have new information
we see all different kinds of
Expressions here it's really difficult
to tell from our seats
and it is so difficult feeling powerless
now but all we can do is Cheer them up
and trust them
currently we have not confirmed the
communication from durander so we have
to assume that
we our
it may uh
we could not complete the grounding on
the lunar surface